Speaker 1: Florida Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis is now trying to cut LGBT subject
matter from an advanced placement psychology
class that is taught in Florida as an optional
class. And the College Board, good for them, is
saying no. The bigger story here, well, there's
really two stories here. There's three stories.
There's 12th. No, there's three as far as I can
tell. One is the subject matter in the curriculum
of this advanced placement psychology class, which
we'll talk about in a moment. The second part of
it is the continued quote, Anti-woke war that Ron
DeSantis is fighting in the state of Florida. And
thirdly is that this is yet another example of how
rightwingers claim to have a particular value.
But then as soon as that value is inconvenient,
they abandon it. And I will tell you about that
in a moment. And it has everything to do with this
subject matter. Being in a psychology class,
which, based on their previous statements, is
something you would think they would be okay with.
So let's go to the beginning. What is going on?
USA Today reports Ron DeSantis wants to scrub AP
classes of LGBTQ subjects. The College Board isn't
having it, and it says another showdown over
advanced placement courses could be brewing
in Florida, this time over AP psychology. As the
nonprofit that runs the program, the College Board
faces pressure from state officials to remove or
revise lessons on sexual orientation and gender
identity. The conflict is another example of
how DeSantis has pushed to restrict how race
and LGBTQ issues are taught is impacting Florida
schools. Florida's Department of Education sent a
letter to the College Board asking them to review
all AP courses to see if they need modification
to ensure compliance with a Florida law that
targets instruction on sexual orientation and
gender identity. The message is clear Remove that
stuff. The College Board responded with a defiant
letter late last week saying We will not modify
our courses to accommodate restrictions teaching
essential college level topics. This could be
a showdown and this class could become a source
of conflict. The Hill also reporting College
Board says it won't alter AP courses to comply
with Florida laws. They put out a letter saying
that this is not something that they are going to
do. Adding doing so would break the fundamental
promise of advanced placement. Colleges wouldn't
broadly accept the course for credit, and that
course wouldn't prepare students for careers in
the discipline. So let's talk about what it is
that is going on here. First of all, this is,
you know, as usual, the way that the Anti-woke
Florida people want to frame these stories are
this is extremely inappropriate stuff being
taught to kids. The reality, of course,
is that this is an advanced placement class.
It's overwhelmingly called high school seniors
and some high school juniors, occasionally a
sophomore. If there are real go getter, you
know what I mean? But it's overwhelmingly seniors
and juniors who are either this year or next year
going to be adults. It is an optional class.
Relatively few people take advanced placement
classes. I'm not saying the raw number is low, but
relatively few people take these classes. When I
took AP Economics in high school, but that was
the one AP class. I took it. It was 12 students
out of 900 or something like that, and that was
it. So nothing is being pushed on anybody. These
are almost legal adults. And most importantly, and
this is the point the College Board is making AP
level classes are. Equivalent to college classes.
You sometimes get credit. I was able to skip
right to Intro to Macroeconomics with Richard
Wolff, by the way, at the University of
Massachusetts, my first semester because I got
credit for AP Micro from high school. So if you
arbitrarily say, we're going to change around
what's in this class, the class is designed to
be a college equivalency class in college.
In psychology class, LGBTQ issues are part
of the subject matter. If you arbitrarily
remove that from the AP high school class,
you endanger that class actually being a college
equivalency class. So it is undeniably. Now,
let let me get now to this next issue. So
first and foremost, doesn't make any sense
to remove. It makes perfect sense to have this
content there. If you are a right winger now,
I what this is an if. Okay, we're doing abstract
thinking. If you are one of the right wingers who
writes to me and says, David, whether it's trans,
even if it's gay. All of this stuff is merely
mental illness. There's no biological basis for
LGBTQ. It's just mental illness. By that standard,
a psychology class is the correct place for this
subject matter. This is a college equivalent
psychology class. I'm not supporting this view,
but what I'm saying is, if you have the view
that LGBTQ issues are merely issues of mental
health that should not be taught to quote kids,
then what better place for them than in a college
equivalent psychology class? Another reminder that
they don't actually mean the things they say they
love, saying These these subjects shouldn't be in
science class. They shouldn't be in biology class.
Well, maybe they should or maybe they shouldn't.
It's quite a large amount of scholarship on
that. But if they shouldn't and you believe
these are simply mental illnesses, then if
not in a college equivalent psychology course,
where the hell do you put this subject matter?
So there's two different views on what Desantis's
doing here. It's mere pandering to
continue this veneer of an anti-woke
warrior in Florida who will bring that anti-woke
perspective to the Oval Office if he is elected.
I don't know that it's just pandering because
this is actual legislate this. There is plenty
of legislation that the Santos has actually signed
into law. These haven't just been PR battles that
go along these lines. The hate legislation in
Florida under DeSantis has been going on for a
period of time now that there may be a pandering
element to it, but it is much more than mere
pandering that we can write off. So that's the
latest battle. By the way, I will restate this
doesn't overall, I mean, listen, maybe you get
away with this. A lot of people won't even hear
about this. A lot of these things, the hardcore
anti-woke trans stuff, the abortion restrictions,
fighting Disney, there actually doesn't seem to be
that much of an appetite for this nationally. And
it may end up hurting DeSantis, or at least not
helping him catch up to Donald Trump, which is,
at the end of the day, what he needs to
do right now in the Republican primary